things are moving very slowly for many
people the disruption started in the
early hours of this morning very slowly
the miles of queues uh behind me very
slowly those vehicles will inch forward
slowly the police here doing a very good
job it has to be said trying to let
through as many frustrated people as
possible both holiday makers but also
lorry drivers as well i've also seen a
few um people charities who are on their
way to the polish ukrainian border
carrying a huge amount of aid they are
obviously keen to get to their
destinations and then here we go the
freight moving ever so slowly here but
you can see it loops all the way
around the top there but slowly they are
getting through many of these drivers
were telling us this morning they they'd
left home left their destinations about
2am 3am and yet they're still stuck in
dover many of them just inching forward
bumper to bumper and it's not just
congestion in the town itself there has
been an arc hughes on the main arteries
into dover not only on the moat ways but
the main a roads too we spoke to some of
those who were stuck in those queues
earlier
it's taken about an hour to move half a
mile if if that so yeah we and we've
missed we've missed our
our ferry crossing now so
uh we're just we're just deliberating
whether it's worth going home or sitting
it out really well it's gone rolling
goodness
you'll not be catching your ferry today
so
we're just starting the traffic now
i've got out of the car
kids are like screaming and what's going
on and i'd sort of come down for
a look see what's happening 36 hours
waiting for no reason
as for the reason for this disruption
well it's a number of things a you've
got that huge disruption to the piano
ferries company a scenario that's been
playing out for the past week or so not
only are you know those all of their
services currently not running but
you've also had another operator dfds
having two of their ships that are two
of their ferries that are currently out
of order um there are services like stun
lines but also irish ferries they are
still running but as you mentioned that
they people are being encouraged to
check with their operator it doesn't get
away from the fact though that so many
of these people have got all sorts in
the back of these cars luggage suitcases
they've got little ones and bikes that
i'm getting ready many of them to get
their easter getaway started not the
start to their holidays though that many
would have imagined